an insanely sweaty Donald Trump has
delivered a visibly confused statement
on immigration I guess this is his
campaign you know for a guy who said
Biden's a loser for running a campaign
from his basement even though Trump lost
to the guy running a campaign from his
basement Trump now I guess this is his
campaign putting to get filming in a
very hot room where he's sweating and
talking about issues he doesn't
understand here is Trump's latest
statement put out yesterday about
immigration
more illegal immigrant oh and that that
volume is out humiliatingly low here we
go let's let's start it over
far more illegal immigrants have entered
the United States in the last two years
that at any time in American history and
by a massive margin now if that is true
what Trump is talking about is we've
caught more people
now if you're catching them aren't you
doing a good job as far as Trump is
concerned
confusing we've never seen anything like
it our country is under Invasion nothing
has dramatically changed on immigration
since Trump left and Biden came in other
than there was a temporary slowdown on
movement of people due to the pandemic
and that has eased but policy wise
almost nothing has changed days ago 16
000 illegal aliens were encountered
crossing the border in a single 48-hour
period Now understand by the way the
jump Cuts because Trump can't string
together more than a sentence at a time
or bizarre remember
what Trump means by encounter is
apprehended
apprehended that sounds like the border
patrol under Biden is doing a pretty
good job by Trump's own standards a
colossal migrant Caravan recently poured
across the Rio Grande and into the
streets of El Paso Texas and the people
and the police didn't know what to do
about it it is truly a massive Invasion
any form of amnesty now would be a
catastrophe it rewards Joe Biden's
lawlessness and it rewards the criminal
cartels and it rewards everyone who has
broken the laws of our nation and again
the first priority on amnesty is people
who have not broken the law kids
individuals who were brought here when
they were legally minors were talking
about DACA it's low-hanging fruit we
should deal with it we could deal with
it they don't want to do it because
they've never done anything to our
country like they're doing right now our
country is being poisoned remember our
border is not open because by the way
dehumanizing language people are
poisoning the country they are so filthy
that they are it's a poison of
insufficient resources or
legal authorities our border is open
because Joe Biden has ordered it to be
open understand that there is no such
policy that Biden has enacted because
Biden has broken the law and torn it
into shreds he has shredded our system
and he's destroying our country Biden
inherited a Flawless deportation system
that was working like never before in
our history we never did so well on the
border as we were doing just a short
time ago now understand that the
deportation system Trump's talking about
is the use of title 42 to more quickly
Deport people that is on the basis of
covid being a global emergency Trump
wants you to believe covet wasn't really
a big deal and and all these red State
Governors were right to do nothing about
it but it was also such a big deal that
you needed an expedited removal process
for migrants wait how can both be true
was covet an emergency or was it not
Trump Administration giving Biden more
resources will simply translate to even
more releases because that's really what
they have in mind all right so none of
this is true and again for a guy who
ridiculed Biden for campaigning from his
basement Trump's campaign in the five to
six weeks since he announced has been to
sit in a hot room and record sweaty
videos it doesn't sound particularly
good and by the way Biden's polling was
much better than Trump seems to be right
now we'll have this clip on our
Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman's show wild and wacky stuff
let's face it the holiday season can be
a stressful time for anyone even a
stressor on relationships in-laws
dividing time mismatched expectations
around gifts our sponsor paired is the
app that makes it easy to maintain a
feeling of connection with your partner
during this crazy time of year you and
your partner download the app you pair
together an everyday paired gives the
two of you questions or quizzes games to
have fun stay emotionally connected
deepen your conversations and all of the
exercises were developed by academic
psychologists and expert relationship
therapists as well my girlfriend and I
have been using paired quite a bit
lately it's fun especially with the baby
these days it's more important than ever
for us to find quality time and parrot
is really the perfect way to spark that
with funny moments meaningful
conversations and we can use paired on
the go don't let end of year stressors
get in the way of you and your partner
enjoying some connecting paired makes it
simple and giving your significant other
a paired subscription is a great last
minute holiday gift head over to
paired.com Pacman for a seven day free
trial and 25 off a subscription the link
is down below